バンカラジオパ俺の名前は天才小学生やす
お寿司が大好物だ
[音楽]
うんおいしい俺寿司開いてみたい
なあんた寿司や舐めてるでしょ寿司切るん
には最低でも中年引きようって言われてん
だからねオリジナル寿司とか作ったら
面白いだろうなそんなこと言ってる暇
まかった勉強なさ
あ
うん美味しいちょっとちょっと待ちなさい
よ
[音楽]
ちょっと
うん
[音楽]
いらっしゃいあやっぱ20年以上通ってる
けど大将の握る死が1番だよどうもお客
さんごち特上握りセットでえ
よしいただき
[音楽]
ますこの寿司うますぎるネタ自体の鮮度が
違うのは言うまでもないがシのほぐれ具合
ネタとシのバランス全てんだ大将なんだ僕
を出しにして
ください逃げんだよやっ
た
おとりあえず最
あお金持ってませんふざけんな
けあのお寿司の握り方勉強したいんです
けど早まるなこそ飯たき3年握る8年まず
は皿洗いからだ
[音楽]
ええまずは1手目で空気穴を開け2手目で
人差し指を添え握り込む3手目で寿司を
払うように返し4手目で左手の指先と親指
で軽く閉める5手目で寿司を180°回転
させ6手目で親指の中指に押し込む最後7
手目で左手を上に添え指先で軽く閉める
これが返し7
手は疲れ
たこそ見習いが寿司の握りの練習をするの
は店の営業行だこれから修行ああ有意に
[音楽]
[拍手]
使えよ
[音楽]
何かが足り
ないそうだ最初に握手した時大将の手は
冷たかった手の温度
[音楽]
だできたああ
おいこそおい
起きろ全く1日目からそんなちゃしてたら
10年持たない
ぞお前が握った寿司かどれ
[音楽]
だれこれお前が握った寿司か
はいお客さん今日はちょっと試食を頼み
たくて
お1つは俺が握った寿しもう1つはその
小僧が握った司どちらか当ててみて
ください僕はもう20年以上大将の土を
食べてるからねこんなん簡単だ
[音楽]
よ1つ目はまあ普通のいって感じか
な2つ目はの具合が神がかっている何年も
主義を教えられた職人の技術が感じられる
文句なしの一品ってことで1つ目が小学生
の握った2つ目が大将の握っただなこれは
簡単
[笑い]
簡単逆
だたった1日でこんなうまい寿司が握れる
のは最だありがとうございますお前の握っ
た寿司でお客さんを笑顔にするんだ
さ大将今までありがとうございまし
[音楽]
た
いらっしゃい
ますお母さんあれれなんでオープン見なの
にお客さんがいないのかしらまだオープン
したばっかだからだよ修行もせずに
オープンした子供のお寿司屋さんなんて誰
が来るのかしらねあらかわいそうあら
かわいそうかわいそう
かわいそういらっしゃい
ませ
おおおお
おなんだこれうますぎ
リットまたお願いし
ますその後お客さんの投稿がSNSで
バズリ屋根寿司は一気に有名になっ
たやすき寿司やすき寿司うまい坊寿司
108円天才やき寿司210ポテチマヨ
寿司108円グランド
[音楽]
オープン寿オープンです
どうぞやりずくださいはよう
うい坊主くださいはいよ寿くださいはい
よ
美しい
おいしい
[音楽]
美しい
でかおここ題の寿司屋じゃん寿司いいね
おいお前ら寿司なんて子供が好きそうな
ものにいちいち反応すんじゃねえよいや
まさ1回行ってみましょう
よしょうがねえ
なおそう
だうおこれうめえなういうめえうんうん
もっとも食べてみてください
[音楽]
よふ
うまおいなんだよこれ最高だよでよねほら
言ってじゃないですかよだろ
こちらのお寿司屋さんなんと小学生が店長
なんです早速中に入ってみ
ましょう小学生が切り盛りするこのお寿司
屋さんなんと大正教なんです陽天才やす
寿司
ですわあ見てくださいこのユニークなお
寿司いただき
まう
おいしいこちらやす寿司の天主のやすさん
ですやすですこのお寿司を作るのにどれ
ぐらい修行されたんですか1日ですたった
1日すごいですねこの寿司屋を作った
きっかけはありますか世界中の人に僕の右
た寿司を食べてもらいたいからです
なるほど寿司やって儲かるの
ね何何てだろね楽しみだね何なるか
なウだ
[音楽]
けおおら意外と欲しいじゃないは
何何してんだよ何やってんだ
よおい
物おっ
ておい何してんだよ何やってるって寿食っ
てんの
よお母さんはできんだから早く帰れ私に
全部任せなさい寿司だけじゃなくこの店の
権利こと私が握ってあげるわはこれから
修行するから待ってなさいみんなも私のお
店ができたら来てね
[音楽]
てっ
てお前
[音楽]
えいらっしゃい私は弟子にしてください
10年耐える覚悟はあるかマのロです
大なんで洗しなきゃいけないのよ皿洗いも
業の一環
だ
[音楽]
やみ
やみ何食ってんだよバビを修行の
よお
およ修行なんて必要ないん
だ美人寿以降美人寿以降真っ黒5000円
雑草寿司3000円ハーゲ脱寿司
1万2000円グランド
オープンあのおばさんの寿司はできた
みたいだし行ってみるかでもこれなんか
まずそうじゃないすか食ってみねえと
わかんねえだろ
くそ
[音楽]
どうぞ
イエー真っ黒くださいせ
おちガソ寿司くださいせ
おちハーゲンダッツ寿司くださいせお
[音楽]
待ちまずうわまずい
ずわまず何これ
まずなこれう
[拍手]
私が私が作ったお寿
よ私のお寿なんで誰も食べてくれないの
[音楽]
シシ
シは体温でぬちぬちだしネタの鮮度も悪い
本当に修行したな1時間でやめてきた
わ俺は寿司がれればそれでいい2人で寿司
を開こうそれじゃ売上は半分ねでも私お
寿司握るのは向いてないわ俺にいい考えが
ある
よお母さん
破壊
大量
[音楽]
大量ファイヤーサーモンください
ファイヤーサーモン入りました
321カ巻き寿司くださいでか巻き寿司
です
お金が大量だちょ2人で頑張ったおかげだ
ねマニ
マニマニマニーマニマニすいませ
ん大将久しぶりだなお店の方はどうですか
実はうちの店は1年前に強盗にあって潰れ
たんだそうだったんですね暗い話はやめな
特上にぎり1個あ
[音楽]
よいやあおいしかった僧これからも俺の
意志を受け継ぐものとして頑張ってくれよ
はいところで強盗の犯人で捕まったんです
かそれがまだなんだこの顔に見覚えはある
かああもうなんでさえないなせなきゃいけ
ないのよ
おのお金じゃない
の
メこれは僕かママ
マ泥棒ばば見つけたぞ
じあなんでこうなるんだ
よちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル
[音楽]
登録